okay I should be live this is very much
last-minute stream see how well the
Wi-Fi holds up I'm currently playing the
warm-up arena the tournament before the
lis chest title arena and okay I'll be
playing significantly lower players in
this tournament compared to the next one
hence why it's a warm-up and I'm not
supposed to be awake at this time it's
currently 138 and in Indonesia woke up
at 5 a.m. earlier today or earlier
yesterday but I've slept so much like we
had some long car rides and I slept for
a couple hours in the car so somehow I'm
awake and I'm attacking I think I want
to just take let's not sack let's take
your first like to take and play Queen
h5 maybe d5 the targets but the rook on
f4 would like to triple up I should
probably not spend so much time drawing
arrows but it's fun to do D fives
hanging should take it while I still can
and I have six coming winning the rook
okay in this case not winning the rook
hmm let's attack the Queen King h1
position feels good but it was like it
couldn't be better let's do this if he
takes my rook I win the Queen
hey I'm winning the Queen
return to f6
some sort of windmill pattern I would
like to meet in somehow the Queen back
on c3
yeah the connection seems decent enough
for a bullet I think there is some lag
with the the ping I'll so many free
gifts feels like Christmas let's just
end this okay
hello to people in the chat you read off
a few names a few names which I can
pronounce Abbey cat meows it's a new
name anchor 1 2 3 etc in no tracks
Square with two S's from the Netherlands
mice just add Lewis here the first mod
to arrive the bets man now everyone's
saying hello Chris HGTV a handy Andy
okay good to see everyone let me know if
things look and sound okay there's some
karaoke going on in the background
there's also birds in the other room who
are tripping occasionally I'm also
streaming from a hotspots in like a
small village and a few days ago the
internet was just really slow but now it
seems to be ok so let's try and play a
few more games yeah the stream just
started like three minutes ago about
greedy Willis welcome back I'm not
taking challengers I'm playing the leech
s bullet arenas first ones a warm-up the
next one is the real deal trying to
remember how to move the pieces mmm
let's just play an Italian play a six
Bishop a seven it's a nice line for
black usually the idea if he plays Ricky
you want I'll play Knight g4
if h3 let's maneuver the Knight to g6
and then I have ideas of pushing d5
maybe I'll throw in h6 as well wow it's
so complicated whenever there is pawns
like this you're supposed to take at
least once a general rule actually I
heard that rule on the perpetual chess
podcast in their interview by Greg
Shahaji
just such a random rule but it actually
makes sense
Iren faith 83 the first year hundred
bits thanks so much
now he's confused took so much time to
recapture and I want to go for like f5 e
for just gain space and be happy
mmm it's not titik preserve the bishop
good move it's a very good move now I
have to think yeah this is gonna be a
little bit annoying but did he just dis
conduct I think he disconnected okay oh
maybe my Internet's the Internet in
Indonesia is better than the Internet
and Iran and so it's good for me a long
time no see the ice welcome back
Mustique you with a sub thanks for the
sub yeah I was really not planning to
stream I had no idea that Tyler you know
is like starting so soon I only found
out because I got the notification that
chest network went live and I wasn't
even gonna look at his stream but he
streamed so rarely that I checked it out
and then I realized he's doing
commentary for the arena was this line
906 let's play Bishop c4 in Queen f3 a
nice variation maybe he'll give me one
of these targets actually I'm guaranteed
to win something that's nice
let's play Queen b3 and be sneaky
he's 1,300 capable and missing
okay now this Bishop I'm gonna just
continue being sneaky and trap the
bishop so I'm up a knight decent
position solid enough and go put the
King on D to a solid formation try and
trade rooks I'm actually really
impressed that like there's no lag and
it feels feels like home
okay c7 let's take a seven I'll have a
passed pawn pass pawns are great in
bullets because you can kind of just
push them or you can check make your
opponent okay
just AdBlue can you show the Belgrade
gambit or Sicilian
yeah this probably won't be the most
instructive stream I'll try and make it
entertaining I could still take opening
recommendations Belgrade gambit is not a
bad recommendation for bullets play the
three before variation again
Scandinavians slow chess yeah it's very
playable in slow chess you just have to
be prepared in this line where black
doesn't fall into the main trap but if
they if they take the pawn and play
accurately there's still like good
enough compensation for whites I think
it's at least equal chances okay
back to tournament I think I'll play one
more at least keep warming up to be
careful not to burn myself out Icelandic
gambit that's in Scandinavian rights
with like some c6 earlier ecigs early
let's play a London because I'll
probably play the London a lot in the
title arena
I usually don't play this slime did this
line is actually very playable a pawn on
f4 is quite nice c5 is under my control
my first time catching a stream nice
every time I stream there's always
someone who's first time it is welcome
first-timers or first-timer there's only
one let's play a queen h5 try and made
them and I'll be a little bit reckless
Castle queenside I want to just push the
pawn in mate
let's recapture here and then okay he
should have taken on e5 but he's trying
to be safe another sub from aim tip Jo
two months in a row thanks let's play h6
I want to create some meeting net and
I'm dominating the only open file
I black is pretty much paralyzed I don't
know how he stops ripped Yeats because
the bishop can't develop and b6 just
hangs a truck so that's nice rekt yet
can be pre moved that's nice okay still
warming up someone in the chat loves me
I love you too but in all seriousness
I'm loving the viewership and support
recently it's been a good start to the
new year I'm trying to do new videos
every day hard to keep up hey another
sub just add blue three months in a row
thanks just add blue I'm gonna play this
b5 line
it's a nice kind of dynamic variation
against a'ready usually transposes into
some clueless Sicilian yeah now this is
pretty much just a clue Sicilian c7 I
have to slow play this a little bit
he's probably going for e5 do this and
try and trade the bishops because this
bishop is better than my Bishop e5 okay
so the position gets a little bit closed
go put the Queen on b6 and go for 94
maybe night I fade first and rook c8 can
slow play a little bit yeah a 94 is nice
see two's hit and if he takes c2 is hit
again and now I just start piling up
let's flip the rook on c3 some nice nice
little orifice and White's territory now
I have a gun maybe g6 whoa free pawn and
the knight is just having a dream square
on e6 and c2 still hanging okay life is
good also Bishop g5 is in the position
let's play f4 it's 96 will defend f4 and
Bishop h4 it could come yeah my knight
so nice
I don't want to trade rooks again I'm
dominating the only open file okay maybe
we'll trade one pair of rooks
and I'll try and win b3 or just flag him
okay
I've not been to Africa yet I'm going to
Africa in a month and a few days but I
have the chess sets I have one like nice
magnetic travel set and then one like
fold upset still trying to keep them in
decent condition okay so we have a
Bishop a5 line f6 is very strange
hmm I'm gonna play like Aronian I think
Aronian played like this against Cara
wanna like some similar variation in
London and I think white wins upon the
black got some compensation but it's
bullets and he's taking a bit too much
time let me ask you guys can people hear
the karaoke in the background or is my
mic good enough to like drown it out
people can hear it hopefully it's some
nice background music okay so my bishop
has to go back to c5 trade my knight can
come to b3 and the Knights are a little
bit superfluous bring the other night to
d4 let's do this
hmm if you take some b5 my bishop will
be happy play a for everything is pretty
much defended I'll put the rook she rook
t1 or it runs into Bishop c2 but never
mind yeah I'm not gonna see I was asked
to sing like a few minutes ago and then
I realize titled arena is starting I can
rap but that's gonna have to hold off
for another time okay now there's an
open file while of my games so far I'm
trying to control the only open file but
they came on e3 hey more bits coward
pawn and a sub from phenomenom anon
or is it just phenomenon that spelled
really ok so he flagged yeah I
appreciate the bits appreciate the sub
at first I thought that said can I sign
for us I don't know sign language but
now I'm realizing it says can you sing
for us I can't sing either ok well I'm
playing a titled player and the not
titled arena it's take and let's play
here and maybe a hoe blunder hey he
blundered f2 can't be defended that's a
miracle
so I'm gaining some rating points at
least oh at Queen e2 I take on f2 and
play Knight e3 wow so nice ok so now
it's time not to mess this up good try
Bishop g5 not a bad strategy
I just blundered Bishop c5 but it's ok I
still have an extra Queen I'll play a
foreign Queen c5 and maybe this next
it's taken Oh in the c2 pawn probably
yeah let's just trade simplify I'd be
happy
Queen b6 and then I can fork the rooks
my King has no very good to go kingi one
Queen c6 and the rook can't come to you
on this can be pre moved
I'm also stopping Bishop c4 okay so that
was nice yeah this is an opening trap I
haven't seen in a while this it comes
from a Kings Indian attack I showed this
to a student a few days ago see if I can
pull up the analysis board
well I showed it from a French blue
border hey it's five hundred bits hey I
am streaming in a normal time in the US
it's like I've been getting comments
that I stream at weird times but I guess
it's it's why it's almost 1:00 p.m. in
like Central Time
it's not bad thanks for the bits me OTT
so I was showing a student the slime
with 92 I think I was recommending them
to take on e4 and then played Bishop c5
how'd it go some line like this where
white like blunders night after day
maybe 9s who has played earlier but some
position like this which we'd
essentially got from a different move
order I'm curious okay no games in the
Masters database more bits from Sarah
Neely oh thanks Sarah nelio b ches okay
so a few hundred games
well I get this question a lot does
chess does your chess income is enough
for living or you need to go some
regular job I mean my job or my main job
is chess coaching but recently it's been
turning into also doing twitch YouTube
and like online courses I have some
different projects coming up
I also freelance a bit with photography
and like website design and so so it's a
mix of different things so the answer is
basically I'm holding off and getting a
so-called regular job at least for the
time being and maybe I'll get into the
industry of doing sleep or of doing
voiceover is for sleepy people might be
a good markets okay so the title arena
is gonna start soon I'll take a quick
break meditation titled arena okay so
this is the one people see this it was a
framing off before I don't know if the
framing is off this over a little bit
yeah I haven't meditated in a while I
shouldn't meditate at least for a few
minutes it's probably not the most
exciting thing to watch on stream though
so maybe I'll just scroll up you can
read the contents in the chat okay hey
another first-time viewer courage 5 try
and say hello to new people if you're
new here feel free to make yourself
known in the chat let me know where
you're from and it also helps to know
like what your what your reading is like
what's the general reading those of
people watching this another sub from
what does that name Mort Allen 1997
thanks for a lot of new subs this stream
it's nice to see
when will I play fortnight's this is a
question as to why I'll go I've never
played fortnight I don't really
understand why it's such a big craze
I know it's popular but I don't know
chess is more interesting at least for
the time being
oh and now a lot of comments oh man I
can't keep up like the the chat is
lagging more than likely chess but okay
a lot of a lot of diverse locations
Brazil Munich Chicago Korea wait
South Korea or North Korea when people
say Korea they usually refer to South
rights Sweden London London's my
favorite opening and my favorite city
Joanna in the chat hello Joanna
well Memphis Florida you're from YouTube
okay
nice location oh I should join the
tournament I forgot to join good timing
so okay I'm I'm ATSC scene number two is
Carlsen but sometimes he doesn't play
from this actual account so like
sometimes he'll play anonymously like
the last time I played them actually the
last time I played the tile arena I I
think was the one that I play them I
somehow beat him in the first game so I
don't think it will happen again but I
mean that's my main goal for this
tournament is to play Carlsen have fun
okay so I'm playing some random GM let's
play of London dedicating this to all
the people from London and the chat
Bishop g3 so I'm gonna go for this
Bishop e5 line if he plays knight c6 v6
okay I've to finish at d3 donation $10
Dave meat and knots thanks Dave needed
nuts if you're gonna donate try to do so
between games but I can't really get mad
at you
do appreciate the support in this
position looks playable let's play
solidly and Castle and maybe you go for
95 eventually a little bit of lag but
not too bad yeah put the knight on e5
trade some stuff my rook probably wants
to be on III so I can lift I had this
ambition for the new year